O. K., Freunde der Sonne.
Bereit für ein paar Schlagzeilen?
"Die Fürze deines Partners
verlängern dein Leben."
"Pupse schützen vor Krankheiten."
"Warum die Pupse des Partners
Ihr Leben verlängern könnten."
Es werden ja immer wieder total
verrückte Dinge
"wissenschaftlich bewiesen".
So verrückt, dass man sich denkt,
das kann ja gar nicht sein.
Andererseits gibt es ja auch
total verrückte Studien.
Z.B. diese, wo Forscher berichteten,
mit wie viel Druck Pinguine kacken.
Es ist also gar nicht mehr
so einfach zu sagen,
ob Schlagzeilen stimmen oder nicht.
Deswegen herzlich willkommen
zu unserem neuen Format
"Schlagzeilen wissenschaftlich
geprüft"!
Heute mit: Ist Pupsriechen gesund?
Hier eine garantiert
wissenschaftliche Antwort,
und so viel verspreche ich euch:
Es wird spannend.
(Titelmusik)
So, wichtige Sache zuerst:
Man sollte Artikel niemals
nur nach der Schlagzeile
oder Überschrift beurteilen.
Deswegen, lasst doch mal schauen, was
genau an Pupsen so gesund sein soll.
(Sie liest vor.)
So viel stimmt, Hydrogensulfid oder
Dihydrogensulfid, müsste man sagen,
ist das Äquivalent zu unserem H2O,
zum Wasser, nur mit Schwefel.
Schwefelwasserstoff
sagt man meistens dazu
oder einfach nur kurz H2S.
H2S ist ein stinkendes Gas,
dem unsere Fürze
ihren Gestank zu verdanken haben.
Sie enthalten auch noch andere
Stinkmoleküle,
aber H2S ist schon einer
der Main Player.
H2S riecht nach verfaulten
Eiern, und zwar brutal.
Das weiß ich als Chemikerin leider
aus eigener Erfahrung,
weil man im Labor auch ab und an
mit H2S hantiert.
In einem Pups ist H2S relativ
verdünnt,
denn er besteht zum größten Teil
aus geruchlosen Gasen.
Aber wir wissen alle, dass auch
solche kleinen Konzentrationen
schon ausreichend
unangenehm sein können.
Im Labor hingegen arbeitet man
normalerweise mit dem reinen Gas,
das beim Einatmen übrigens giftig ist
und ab einer gewissen Konzentration
den Geruchssinn betäubt.
D.h., wenn ihr mal im Labor
mit H2S arbeiten solltet
und es plötzlich nicht mehr stinkt,
dann get the fuck out!
O. K., und warum sollte man das
jetzt schnüffeln?
(Sie liest vor.)
Naja, wie gesagt, es ist auch ein
Gift. Aber die Dosis macht das Gift.
Und H2S wird tatsächlich
in winzigen kontrollierten Mengen
auch in unseren Zellen produziert.
In diesem "Bild"-Artikel
wird erklärt:
Hydrogensulfid soll gut sein
für die Mitochondrien,
die "Kraftwerke" der Zellen.
Auch das stimmt.
Die Mitochondrien sind die
"Kraftwerke" unserer Zellen.
Sie halten unsere Zellen
also am Leben.
Werden sie geschädigt,
kann das zusammenhängen
mit verschiedenen Krankheiten
wie Herzversagen, Schlaganfällen,
Diabetes, Demenz.
Auf molekularer Ebene spielt hier
der "oxidative Stress" eine Rolle.
Dabei entstehen reaktive, aggressive
Sauerstoffverbindungen,
Oxidationsmittel,
die die Zelle schädigen
oder töten können.
Für solche Fälle hat das
Mitochondrium aber Methoden,
sich zu schützen.
Wenn es unteroxidativen Stress gerät,
bestellt es Enzyme,
die H2S produzieren
in ganz kleinen Mengen.
Und das hilft dem Mitochondrium
dabei,
durchzupowern und die Zelle
am Leben zu halten.
Insofern hilft H2S beim Schutz
vor Krankheiten.
Diesen körpereigenen
Mitochondrien-Überlebensmechanismus
versuchen jetzt Forscher
zu imitieren.
Sie versuchen
Medikamente herzustellen,
die genau wie diese Enzyme
auch H2S produzieren
in kleinen kontrollierten Mengen.
Genau so auch in dieser Studie.
Das ist nämlich die Studie,
auf die sich diese ganzen
"Pupse riechen ist gesund"-
Schlagzeilen beziehen.
Aber warum jetzt so mühsam
H2S-Medikamente entwickeln,
wenn man doch stattdessen einfach
an Pupsen schnüffeln kann?
Weil es halt einen Unterschied macht,
ob man etwas einatmet
und dann auch noch
unbestimmte Mengen davon,
oder ob man etwas gezielt im Inneren
einer Zelle kontrolliert freisetzt.
Es ist jetzt nicht prinzipiell
abwegig,
dass ein Wirkstoff nicht auch
übers Einatmen, über die Lunge,
ins Innere unserer Zellen
gelangen könnte.
Aber diese Form der Zulieferung
ist sicher nicht besonders
kontrolliert oder zielgerichtet.
Damit das klar ist, die Forscher
haben H2S-Einatmen nicht untersucht -
v.a., weil es auch nicht chemisch,
biologisch plausibel wäre,
dass das irgendwas bringt -
geschweige denn, untersucht,
wie es ist, Pupse einzuatmen.
Das ist in dieser Studie
noch nicht mal ansatzweise passiert.
Schaut man in die Pressemitteilung
der Uni,
so werden Fürze zwar auch
als lustige Aufhänger benutzt.
Aber auch hier steht nirgends,
dass man sie einatmen sollte.
D. h., Pupseriechen ist nicht gesund
und all diese Überschriften
und die grundlegenden Behauptungen
in diesen Artikeln sind alle falsch.
(Pups)
Gerade bei Populärwissenschaft
ist es leider oft so,
dass irgendjemand irgendetwas
Verrücktes über eine Studie schreibt
und andere das einfach aufgreifen,
nachplappern, kopieren,
ihre eigenen Artikel schreiben,
verbreiten,
ohne die Originalstudie zu lesen.
Ich frage mich auch,
wer auf die Idee kam,
jetzt speziell die Pupse des Partners
zum Thema zu machen.
"Wir wissen zwar nicht,
warum zur Hölle Forscher die Pupse
von Paaren untersucht haben..."
Ja, vielleicht, weil die Forscher
das nie untersucht haben!
Obwohl, so sicher wäre ich mir da
noch nicht mal.
Noch mal: Es gibt seltsame Studien.
Wenn euch dieses Format gefallen hat,
lasst es mich wissen.
Dann mache ich das in Zukunft
gerne wieder.
Aber am besten noch mit eurer Hilfe.
D.h., wenn ihr irgendwo
eine verrückte Schlagzeile seht
über eine Studie, die mal wieder
irgendetwas gezeigt hat
und ihr wissen wollt,
ob es wirklich stimmt,
teilt diesen Link über Twitter
mit mir oder Lars
und dem Hashtag #prüfdieschlagzeile.
Natürlich könnt ihr auch sehr gerne
Schlagzeilen unter diesem Hashtag
in die Kommentare schreiben.
Nur, Achtung, Kommentare mit Links
werden von YouTube
manchmal automatisch
in den Spam-Ordner geschoben.
Wenn ihr sichergehen wollt,
am besten einfach nur die Schlagzeile
als Text kopieren
und als Kommentar posten.
Ich kann das dann auch selber
googeln.
Also, #prüfdieschlagzeile,
wir sehen uns nächste Woche,
bis dahin, bleibt sicher!
- Ich muss mehr so.
(Lachen)
- Kann ich jetzt pupsen?
- (Lachen) Nein!
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von funk (2019)